cette personne Matthieu Delormeau m'a
brisé le coeur elle a joué avec ma
confiance mais tu voulais le faire
en Grèce en Grèce
pendant vos petits camarades sont en
train de travailler et de te tuer pour
faire des records
tu es un lieu de tournage non
vous êtes en train de vous rapprocher
vont dire un mot sur vous parce que en
fait Mathieu et comme son public de TPMP
people le weekend il part très très loin
de la France et ça se voit le dimanche
matin à 9h30
aurait été aperçu en train de danser sur
la table en remuant son shaker de prod
de manière
et il aurait fini la soirée très tard
dans la nuit dans un établissement qui
s'appelle l'Open Flamingo et il y aurait
bu quelques verres et bouffer quelques
culs
[Applaudissements]